وقع حسوم مسعود كرئيس للوزراء بالوكاله
وثيقه يفوض فيها فرنسا بتنفيذ ضربات داخل
القصر الرئاسي
اخبار العالم بانجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تطورات جديده في النيجر
قاده الانقلاب يتهمون حكومه
بتفويض فرنسا لشن ضربات باريس ترد بانها
لا تعترف الا بسلطه وانه لا هدف لها سوى
سلامه مواطنيها ومصالحها والاتحاد
الاوروبي يبدي دعمه لمقررات هيكواس ولندا
وبرلين تعلقان دعمهما الملك
خلال تحرك احتجاجي امام البرلمان السويدي
عراقيان يقدمان على حرق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف وتدنيسه بعد ان منحت الحكومه الاذن
لاقامه الاحتجاج احد الشابين يقول انه لن
يتوقف عن حرق نسخ من المصحف حتى يتم حضره
في البلاد
لي اليوم الثالث على التوالي الاشتباكات
بين مسلحين في مخيم عين الحلوه جنوبيه
لبنان تستمر ممثلون للفصائل الفلسطينيه
واحزاب لبنانيه يتفقون على وقف اطلاق
النار وسحب المسلحين من شوارع المخيم
وفصائل فلسطينيه تحذر من خطوره تهجير
الفلسطينيين من المخيم ونتائجه على الوجود
الفلسطيني
اربعه قتل احوى عشرات العصابات في هجوم
روسي جديد استهدف مدينه كريفيريا
الاوكرانيه في المقابل السلطات الروسيه
تعلن تعرضها لهجوم اوكرانيا بطائرات مسيره
على ابراج سكنيه
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في تعلن سقوط
قاتلين في قصف صاروخيا اصاب حافله ركابا
الى اللقاء